olivier marleix hxc par la fermeté qu'on
résout une crise migratoire une question
il rate war oui sans doute nous c'est
pas par ce texte si c'est votre votre
votre question donc quelques la manche
ce texte c'est puisque c'est ça le point
de départ quand même c'est c'est la
parfaite illustration de l'illusion
macro nien c'est à dire que l'on me
présente un texte en faisant croire aux
français que ça va changer quelque chose
ce texte c'est au mieux un texte de
réforme de l'engorgement des préfectures
quoi voilà c'est là que ça a peut-être
un peu d'effet avec des mesures hyper
technocratique mais qui ne changeront
pas grand chose la réalité ce même les
modifications du sénat n'y changeront
pas grand chose alors on va pas rester
sur les modifications du sénat
malheureusement je pense qu'elle ne fait
pas de doute sur le fait que la majorité
revienne à son à son à son texte en
réalité c'est que en termes de
reconduite à la frontière de notre pays
avec monsieur macron sur l'année 2017
on est à deux fois moins que sur le
dernier rallye nicolas sarkozy on est
passé de près de quarante mille ha à
moins de 20000 donc il n'y a pas deux il
n'y a pas de volonté
la ligne du président de la république
puisque on a une semaine la question
migratoire est au devant de scène elle
est totalement illisible et pardon mais
j'ai vraiment le sentiment qu'on a un
président de la république qui n'a pas
de colonne vertébrale sur ce sujet là en
tout cas j'irais le lundi on refuse
d'accueillir les migrants de l'aquarius
jeune âge me réjouit mais le mardi on
dit qu'on va accueillir une partie des
migrants du lifeline je passe une dans
des bateaux qui avec une importance dans
le choix du canda république peut-être
eu un jour on est d'accord il ne faut
pas venir en aide se courir de façon
humanitaire ces personnes en difficulté
en méditerranée c'est qu'on peut pas le
un jour est d'accord avec les espagnols
qui disent il faut accueillir sur notre
territoire et des centres d'accueil
et puis le lendemain est d'accord avec
les italiens qui disent non c'est dans
les pays d'origine qu'il faut accueillir
tout ça est totalement totalement
incohérent ya pas de colonne vertébrale
n'y a pas de ligne le sujet c'est que on
est face à une crise migratoire sans
précédent pourquoi sans précédent parce
qu'en fait c'est une crise d'abord
démographique le continent africain
qu'il faut aujourd'hui à un peu plus
d'un milliard d'habitants va dans les
quarante ans qui viennent
doublé de population de rats on va
passer de 1 2 milliards après 2,5
milliards on sait que les flux qui
traversent la méditerranée enfin c'est
ça les réalités qu'il faut que nous que
nos compatriotes et en tête quand on a
découvert les phénomènes au moment de
lampedusa en 2012 y avait environ 500000
personnes qui commençait à traverser la
méditerranée chaque année aujourd'hui on
estime qu'on est à plus d'un million de
personnes
le pic c'était en 2015 depuis ces flux
migratoires ont diminué non ces flux non
non non pas diminuer la traversée de la
méditerranée justement ces flux continue
d'augmenter on est passé de 500 milles
influent qui est aujourd'hui de l'ordre
de 2 d'un million on nous a raconté que
c'était des réfugiés tu es très très
clairement sur des réfugiés de rien du
tout j'ai vu qu'il y avait un bateau qui
avait été arrêté parce qu'ils avaient
viré des gens
ddd des migrants avaient viré d'autres
migrants par dessus par dessus bord qui
est ce qui montre quand même
l'empathie dont ils sont eux mêmes
capables
bien que pape a mis ces gens là il y
avait des gens qui venaient du sénégal
expliquez-moi depuis quand chez nadia
détention suivant bien c'est au niveau
européen que cela se joue après neuf
heures de discussions dans la nuit de
jeudi à vendredi l'union européenne
s'est mis d'accord sur un accord sur
cette politique migratoire est ce que
vous vous en féliciter cet accord est
ridicule de france c'est vraiment j'ai
passé c'est la soupe concerts dans les
auberges espagnoles quoi aussi un chacun
est venu avec la phrase qu'il avait
besoin de mettre de montrer à sion
d'opinion d'après plateforme d'accueil
hors des frontières européennes en
europe sur la base du volontariat
cette participation financière y compris
des pays du groupe qu'on appelle devise
grade
ce n'est pas suffisant c'est une vision
c'est une vision commune partagée par
pas par l'europe et en europe vous avez
aujourd'hui de ligne savaient ce qu'ils
disent stop n'avons plus les capacités
d'accueillir et vous avez ce s'est
exprimé d'ailleurs assez largement lors
dès lors des élections certain nombre de
ces pays avec des conséquences que l'on
a vu le ministre de l'intérieur allemand
a dit stop on ne peut plus accueillir
alors que l'allemagne est à l'origine en
grande partie ce vrai que vous avez ceux
comme les espagnols qui disent il faut
continuer on peut continuer à cueillir
devoir de solidarité et c'était un
nouveau chef de gouvernement verra
combien de temps il tiendra on a mis
tout ça bout à bout ça ne fait pas une
politique européenne ce dont on a besoin
c'est d'une rupture d'une politique
européenne qui fasse qu'enfin on
défendre des frontières européennes
cette part dans cette rupture et n'a pas
été fait pourquoi parce que monsieur
macro n'en a pas voulu
monsieur macron s'est alignée sur la
ligne de ceux qui restent sur une
politique immigrationniste d'accueil
braz ouvert de tout le monde même s'il
fait semblant de se défendre dans notre
pays mais juste pour finir sur ce texte
que il y aura une commission mixte
paritaire le 4 juin prochain qui est
vouée à l'échec si on prend bien est-ce
que du coup la majorité de droite la
droite ne donne pas finalement le
bourreau le gouvernement qui pourra
jouer la carte de l'humanisme je sais
pas si de quelques artisans envie de
jouer ce sera entre autres jus quand
j'écoute monsieur macro moi je je je je
vois en lui le fils spirituel de
françois hollande ayant accueilli
léonard da à fin mai on est vraiment à
peu près à ce niveau là aujourd'hui de
vision stratégique sur notre pays sur la
politique migratoire qui devait celle de
la france et de l'europe